during the second century AD the known
world sorry America's was flanked by two
great empires to the west set the Roman
Empire and to the east lay the Han
Dynasty both of these powers sat at the
end of the Silk Road trade route which
saw Goods move mostly from China to roam
across continents and both of these
empires had a great deal in common they
were geographically large they were run
by emperors they had professional armies
and they were plagued by the barbarian
neighbors this obviously raises the
question what did these two know about
each other surely Rome and China had
some idea of each other's existence and
maintained some sort of contact so first
of all both the Roman Empire and Han
China were aware of each other and both
knew that the other was a great Empire
the Chinese mostly new Rome as de Keene
which means great China implying that
China saw Rome as its equal on the other
side of the world and the Romans knew
China by the name Sara Kura much like
how they saw everyone else they saw them
as utterly inferior the most obvious
contact they kept with each other was by
a trade through India the Persian Empire
revived the northern trade routes across
the Black Sea that's not to say it was a
one-way though the Chinese imported a
great deal from Rome most notably glass
the Chinese court was stuffed with Roman
luxury goods and it was a mark of
extreme wealth to own Roman glassware
and this is actually one of the reasons
that the Roman Empire was often referred
to as the treasure country by Chinese
bureaucrats as for the Roman idea of
China well it was much less flattering
partly due to Roman ideals surrounding
stoicism the import of luxuries like
silk and precious stones were seen as
immoral and decadent and given the roman
dislike for running a trade deficit
china was seen as a hostile Empire even
if it was a world away and in fact many
Romans believed that it was Rome's fate
to one day conquer China anyway beyond
economic ties how did Roman China
interact of the two great empires China
was the first to attempt to establish
former diplomatic contact and this was
when a man called Daniel was tasked with
travelling to Rome now he never actually
got there partially because it took
years of travel time and also because
his travels took him through the Persian
Empire and the Persians told him how he
would likely never return home if he
attempted to reach Rome as a result he
turned back and the Persians gave a sigh
of relief since they didn't want China
and Rome to become friends after ying
the hand reported that an ambassador of
qing andin which is likely either
Antoninus pious or marcus aurelius
Antoninus arrived in china in 166 ad
however the evidence of this is sketchy
and there's no certainty of whether or
not the two held formal relations and in
fact they simply could have been traders
and so all too
there isn't enough concrete evidence to
assert that whether or not the two great
empires made any sort of concerted
effort to talk to one another
the Chinese certainly took a greater
interest in the Romans than the Romans
did in them but this didn't mean that
the Romans knew nothing of Han China
they knew it was a great Empire of a men
12 whose exports affected both the Roman
economy and also Roman morality whereas
the Chinese knew that Rome was also a
grand Empire in a land of immense
treasures as such we know that they
certainly 100% knew of each other's
existence and traded a great deal I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching but thanks to my patreon
supporters whom you can see on screen
now and with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette Ike Danny Maloney
calling Castleman Marvin Castle Rob
Waterhouse Aaron the white Jordan long
way Chris wicker Gustav Swann Gareth
Turner
Marcus Ozma Maggie packs Kowski David
Silverman spinning three plates
Spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Winston
Cawood Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell par shoe 19 and Moe